[Applause]  lebron try to put a move on  now a little dance lebron spinning  lebron shooting lebron scoring  go right into go bear too i mean  right into gobert  there's three minutes and 17 left as  lebron puts it up puts it in and it's a  94-91 game  [Music]  i hope you're enjoying it on spectrum  sports net bob dynamics no up the ladder  goes monk to get it lakers could  possibly tie it on his possession under  three to play for the tie for the tie  lebron james but it's russ to him a  fresh 14.  westbrook  looking inside here comes the front  here's lebron  every time russell west will get them to  the paint  and it is lebron on the way  [Applause]  oh lebron lebron lebron why did they  want to switch that  because the bear had to get  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  yes sir the youngster